finding your dream home in the Valley
can be a real challenge right now is
inventory is low it may can get lean
more toward a seller's market but there
are some things you can do to find the
house that's right for you Kirby
Scofield owner of Scofield Realty the
sponsor of this segment joins us with
some ideas thanks for being here guys
thank you Kendall it is hard right now
for the buyers it has so it's become
like it did a year ago so having the
right realtor working for you is key you
want to make sure that someone full-time
dedicate and they know the market yeah
because doing it on your own you're
probably going to get left in the dust
yeah it's going to be hard even if
you're um a seller who's trying to sell
on your own get a realtor because you
want to be able to negotiate it's going
to be a fierce War for the summer here
of winning offers yeah and I I've talked
to other Realtors who say the house goes
on the market and there can be 15 offers
in no time flat yeah so uh pre-plan what
you're looking at be pre-approved have
everything ready and contact our team uh
we have a 2500 sign on bonus to track
new talent and we train the right way
into how to negotiate and win those
offers yeah you're also in Partnership
if you will with Zillow you have
something called Zillow Flex yeah so
Zillow Flex We were blessed with about
two years ago uh February two years ago
we used to pay like a lot of people our
Premier agents so they put their credit
card you buy a zip code due to our
conversion our customer service scores
we were blessed with the zoflex
partnership there's one we're one of
eight Partners in town and our teams of
our 75 agents are all Flex Partners so
when you're on Zillow and you click to
live connect to an agent that is one of
us with flex and then we get out there
get the appointment and get you that
added level of credibility for you guys
and you mentioned uh your Realtors your
team it's growing and you're looking for
more members uh yes because our uh our
inflow it's kind of those funny things
even though the inventory Shrunk the
demand has went up so our connections
have increased and with that I need more
agents to handle the connections we're
getting from Zillow and you have some
perks along those lines to attract the
right people yes uh 2500 sign on signing
bonus we also have just increase our
splits so that they will pay the agent
more in their pocket and we have a very
uh significant mentorship program to
help train them to make sure that their
Windows offers not just spinning the
wheel so even if someone does not come
in with a lot of experience they're
they're going to find the way 100 if
you're coachable we will make you money
all right Kirby great to have you with
us and uh thanks again for the Insight
thank you to Scofield Realty for
sponsoring the segment and they are
looking for new Talent so you do get a
2500 signing bonus if you joined their
team there are some terms that apply you
can call that phone number on the screen
702-766-3795 or go to the website
schofieldrealty.com Rocky